[Music]
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host jared as paul is stuck in
traffic somewhere in the european
countryside so i'm uh send your regards
but in this video we're going to be
breaking down the added scenes to the
new version of spider-man no way home
that is back in movie theaters cleverly
named spider-man no way home the more
pun i mean fun stuff version
sony you're a modern-day version of don
draper with that one keep it up but if
you want to stick around for videos on
your favorite spidey menace then make
sure you web sling that thumbs up button
and also subscribe to the channel with
that out of the way thank you for
clicking this now let's swing into the
more fun stuff spoiler verse with these
new scenes okay so before the more fun
stuff version of the movie even kicks
off there's a zoom call between the
three peters tom andrew and toby
respectively essentially thanking the
fans for supporting the film turning it
into something much more than just
another spider-man film toby says that
it was a beautiful experience for
himself and then both toby and tom
surprise andrew by saying that they love
him which is a callback to the
improvised line from andrew saying that
he loved the other two spider-men during
the final fight at the statue of liberty
it doesn't necessarily add to the film
but it is cool to see how much this film
meant to the three of them now covering
the scenes in order we get a bit of an
extension of the damage control
interrogation scenes specifically
between agent cleary and peter clary
questions peter on why most of his
targets were monuments or attractions
like the washington monument and fairy
boat in homecoming along with the tower
bridge in london along with the ferris
wheel in far from home obviously cleary
believes that there's an overarching
agenda that peter has in his sights even
roping in the night monkey asking who
their true identity was which is cheeky
call back to you know far from home
because the night monkey is is peter
cleary questions aunt may and a couple
of added lines here or there and
honestly i'm surprised this was a huge
missed opportunity
not to reference my cousin vinnie she
was in that movie she was the star of
that movie i'm surprised that they just
didn't throw a line in there for you
know the parents the older people out
there just you know the mcu likes making
references and cameos
just do it now if you remember the
lead-up to spider-man no way home there
were talks that tom holland's brother
harry was supposed to be in the film
playing like a street thug with
spider-man stopping him stringing him up
outside of a storefront well lucky
enough the full scene makes an
appearance this go around and pretty
much follows this like beat for beat
harry is chased after stealing someone's
handbag webbed up by spider-man with
spidey taking the bag from him however
this is where things get a little
comical i mean i guess comical is a
broad term right here when more and more
passerby stop to argue whether or not
spider-man should even be helping people
this essentially escalates into the
original patron questioning whether or
not this whole crime thug thing is an
elaborate set up by spider-man himself
this is where the green paint comes into
play that we see peter trying to scrub
off of his suit later in the film
forcing him to turn his suit inside out
a mysterio supporter runs out of nowhere
it's a bit clunky to be honest tossing
the green paint on his suit yelling
murderer and then running off exclaiming
mysterio was right
i don't know it's nice to see harry's
scene make it into the final movie but
the biggest takeaway that i see here is
like the street level everyday citizen's
view of spider-man after his big scandal
i do wish that there would have been
more mysterio influences rather than a
simple run by painting maybe more you
know of a mysterio cult emerging but the
run time would have definitely felt
bloated if they would have leaned more
into that honestly a lot of the scenes
are wedged into the opening hour of this
film underwhelming like socks for
christmas leaving a lot to be desired
for example a quick couple second clip
of j jonah jameson calling the mayor a
dingus during a daily bugle broadcast
allowing peter parker to go back into
school which then leads to peter doing
the like walk of fame for his classmates
ending in a couple second stinger
revealing a random student almost
looking directly into the camera in
amazement saying i can't believe he was
my lab partner are we supposed to know
this dude now what may be my favorite
added scene is peter in gym class with
his teacher mr wilson played by hannibal
burris as you remember wilson isn't too
fond of peter believing in the
conspiracies of mysterio saying that
mysterio was right basically he doesn't
like spider-man at all and in this scene
in the same bullying fashion that any
high school gym teacher would do he
starts picking on peter by leading a
chant of climate climb it
climb it slowly getting more and more
students to join him a defeated peter
parker then leaps onto the wall of the
gym and the crowd gasp as a silence
falls over them like a oh [ __ ] are you
seeing this right now peter begrudgingly
climbs the wall as the camera pans back
over to mr wilson and with the most
deadpan astonished look on his face he
says
look at that sticky bastard go
i audibly laughed at this one along with
most of my theater showing again aside
from pumping in the added fun and comedy
this scene doesn't necessarily enhance
anything but the single line from
hannibal really got me then there's a
random clip of flash signing his
flashpoint book for fellow students in
the hallway why is this in here who
knows does it add anything absolutely
not now the biggest section like a solid
three-ish minutes are these random
interviews from betty brandt with other
classmates teachers essentially all of
the cast for the school's news channel
she asks questions about you know what
kind of conspiracies they believe in she
asks ned what's an inappropriate text to
send at midnight and how peter would
react if he could talk to the spider
that bit him would he thank the spider
or say thanks a lot spider clips from
this section were actually used on like
i think the daily bugle tick tock page
when the film was rolling out in
theaters for marketing and it feels like
added footage that they had on a shelf
somewhere and they're just like shove it
into this movie who cares but it is a
little funny because of how bad they
purposely make the green screen look
along with the weird interview questions
that betty is asking the undercroft
montage was one sequence that i was
actually looking forward to you know the
group of kids dealing with the different
villains making fun of their names
because of the alliteration but this
sequence all boiled down to adding like
three shots to the prep montage of
setting up their essentially like bass
command ned needs to plug in his
computer pulse an extension cord and a
bunch of boxes just fall because of it i
guess yay
cinema folks but one interesting titbit
i mean tidbit uh wow speaking is
difficult is a weird diorama of the
sanctum sanctorum on the table that mj
investigates after a closer look the
light where the seal of vishanti is on
on the building a shadowy figure is
walking around you know in this tiny
building honestly i think it's just dr
strange like spying on the kids
downstairs but it does feel like it's
really weird to have it added there if
it doesn't really add up to anything
maybe there's more here maybe i'm
missing something i'm not entirely sure
jay jonah jameson yet again has another
daily bugle bit which i gotta say is the
funniest of all of them in this i don't
know why they really cut it but it's an
electric grid worker that calls into the
show talking about how he saw the fight
go down between spider-man electro and
sandman the night before and it's
perfect because of the literal nature of
what this worker is saying so like he
was talking to the dirt man right before
the power monster disappeared with some
sparkly web i mean i'm no geologist but
he summed that up pretty well now adding
to the cheeky fun of the movie is the
elevator scene with all of the villains
going up to happy's apartment this scene
has actually been like released or shown
many times already and it's essentially
you know like five or six seconds
watching it as our characters calmly
ride up in the elevator and again it's
zero stakes but it's a fun little scene
sort of encapsulating all of the fun
that the characters had during the set
of you know filming this movie that
we've seen in some of the behind the
scenes footage word on the street that
the reason it was cut from the final
film is because john watts wanted to
keep the pacing moving for this and to
be honest in this scene it does sort of
slow things down a little bit however i
think the ride up is perfectly
juxtaposed with the aftermath of what
happens in the apartment mirroring the
calm cool and collected ride up with the
pure mayhem chaos and green goblin
spinebuster on the way down oh yeah
spidey i'm about to gwen stacy you
it's a fun scene what else do you want
from me actually the night at the
roxbury head bob could have been a nice
touch here now happy's very good lawyer
was a scene that was rumored to be a
deleted scene however didn't make it
into the blu-ray extra features those
greedy sony execs deprive me of happy
how dare they well guess what it's
included here so how generous of them
earlier in the film when matt murdock is
meeting with peter aunt may and happy he
tells happy he's going to have to lawyer
up because damage control isn't coming
for 30
of his stark tech they are coming for
everything okay that didn't actually
happen but he did say he's gonna need a
good lawyer because the feds still have
questions for him this scene then sees
matt murdock and happy in a conference
room talking with damage control agent
cleary with a handful of other agents
and lawyers at this time happy's phone
vibrates with a notification from his
security camera in his apartment and
this is the same black and white
security footage that shows the villains
peter and aunt may sneaking into his
apartment happy obviously reacts in a
panicky matter with matt leaning over
and telling him hey stop sweating happy
still with a frantic look on his face is
like how do i do that not much added
aside from you know these cute jokes but
also somewhat meta to see matt murdock
and foggy practicing law together again
because like you know happy is played by
john favreau and and he played foggy in
the 2003 uh daredevil movie but matt
murdock was a different person and he
was played by you know what never mind
it's matt murdock being matt murdock and
happy being anxiously happy there were
rumors of extended scenes amongst the
three different spider-man where you
know they're waiting for the villains to
approach the statue of liberty and it's
kind of this fun banter between the
three of them however it seems like they
only kind of added a line here or there
between what was already in the
theatrical version at first it touches
on some emotional beats with them
bringing up like second chances which in
andrew's case you know ties back to his
inability to save gwen in the amazing
spider-man 2 but is also almost like
this cool foreshadowing for his
redemption by saving mj later in the
film during that statue of liberty fight
and maybe i'm looking too deep into this
conversation who knows but i feel like
it's almost a self-aware line from
andrew himself about how he never got to
finish his amazing spider-man trilogy as
you know sony pulled the plug on that
one they went a different direction
rebooting the character adding him to
the mcu this was andrew's almost second
chance at putting on the suit once again
and who knows with the positive
reception to his portrayal of this
character he might actually get another
shot to you know finish this trilogy but
uh um gwen um already had her rice
krispies snap crackled and popped she
ain't coming back sorry buddy anyway the
rest of the conversation is just funny
banter between them about how they don't
understand toby maguire's self-producing
web fluid how often he has a clean
release which has got to be a euphemism
for shooting ropes and after all of this
andrew spider-man says he wants to see
his holes
yeah things get a little weird and
sticky in this version and lastly
there's an actual proper post-credits
scene marvel fans rejoice because the
multiverse of madness trailer is out and
a final send-off from betty the baddie
is in the scene first focuses on a
television in the hallway of the school
between classes talking about graduation
photos and a really cheesy psa about
school lunchroom safety which i didn't
know needed a psa of itself but then
closing on a segment from betty so this
is modeled after a high school
graduation-esque final breakfast club
wrap-up with betty saying we've had all
of these memories together almost died a
couple times i mean who hasn't but who
can forget the experiences the fun and
the events we all had together while
she's narrating this it's showing clips
and photos from the events of homecoming
and far from home like the decathlon and
the european trip however the one thing
missing from every single one of these
clips and photos is peter it's not that
he was marty mcfly back to the future
erased from these photos but rather he
is either cropped out or a funny one
where there's a bird flying in front of
the photo and the bird is covering his
face essentially he got mike wazowski'd
here but it's sort of an emotional look
back at all of the events he experienced
while the world and no one else
remembers him being there this also does
a wonderful job of essentially
illustrating how dr strange's spell
actually worked everyone still has all
of these memories of this time however
without any inkling of peter i'm
surprised this wasn't included in the
theatrical version solely to better
explain peter's status at the end of no
way home plus it shows that this is the
end of the run for some characters
they've graduated they're all going to
be moving on some will go off and do big
things while others will be hired to
host a youtube channel you know you
can't determine your own future you just
go with the flow
anyway that's all of the more pun stuff
scenes that were added into the new
version of no way home aside from some
random one-off lines here or there or
maybe a random joke aside from that this
is pretty much the same version of no
way home they should have honestly just
called this movie spider-man no way home
the more money because the morbius
morbid time re-released that we tried to
do didn't work version i don't know i'm
thinking of directors cuts and other
versions of films like the once upon a
deadpool christmas pg re-release they at
least you know did a couple different
things there was a lot of different
jokes like this feels like a real bummer
for anyone that's expecting it to be
packed full of deleted scenes and
blu-ray extras anyway i hope you enjoyed
this video and obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts on whether or not
this more fun stuff version of your
favorite spider-man movie was worth the
ticket price and if some of the scenes
should have actually made it into the
final cut of the film we're currently
running a competition right now giving
away three copies of top gun maverick on
the 15th of september and all you have
to do to be in a chance for winning is
like this video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your own thoughts on this
more fun version we picked the comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so if that is you
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch be
sure to check out some of our other cool
videos right over there whether it be
the twerking she-hulk or the fiery
dragons of house of dragon click on one
you know you want to with that out of
the way thanks for sticking through this
whole video i've been jared and paul is
still stuck in traffic someone order the
man in uber i'll see you in the next one
take care and peace